字幕: Mimi Uzura
校正: Emi Atarashi
「祈りの花瓶」は 長崎に投下された
原子爆弾の熱風によって変形した瓶
その3Dデータをもとに
長崎の波佐見焼という陶磁器で作った
祈るための花瓶になります
こちらですが
これはアートとして
平和の大切さを伝えていくもの
さらには 被爆資料として
過去を継承していくもの
また 身近に置いて
平和を祈る花瓶として使える
いろんな角度から
平和の大切さを感じていただける
そのような作品になっています
［なぜ被爆したガラス瓶の
レプリカを作ろうと思ったのですか？］
祈りの花瓶とは別に
被爆瓶のレプリカを
作成しているんですけれども
こちらがレプリカの瓶になります
やはり長崎
被爆地長崎には
被爆した資料というものだったり
被爆遺構が残っていたり
被爆者の方が
身近にいらっしゃったり
そういう原爆だったり
平和に考える時間というものが
たくさんある土地だな
というふうに思っています
ただ そういうものに触れようと思うと
やはり 広島、長崎の原爆資料館に
足を運ばなければいけないというところで
どうしても
あまり興味がない人には
ハードルが高くなってしまうのかな
というふうに考えていました
そこで やはりその被爆資料が
残されている意味としては
平和の大切さを伝えていくために保存して
今も残っていると思うので
その貴重な資料に触れるきっかけを
作品で どうにかして解決できないかな
というふうに考えました
そこで 被爆した瓶を3Dスキャンして
レプリカを作ろうというふうに考えました
また 被爆資料は
過去の原爆の被害を受けているので
壊れやすかったり
破損の恐れがあるというところで
あまり気軽に触ることが
できない資料になっています
ただ それをレプリカにすることで
いろんな場所で
破損だったり 劣化を気にせずに
触れることができる
そういうふうに考えました
［どのような展示をしましたか？］
2017年に Vase To Pray Project
というものを立ち上げました
その当時から「祈りの花瓶展」というものを
開催してきました
2017年当初の展示では
3Dプリンターで再現した
ナイロン製の祈りの花瓶というものを
展示していたんですけれども
3Dプリンターで再現することで
どんな場所でも
どんな時間でも触れるという意図で
長崎と東京の２カ所で
展示を開催しました
その後も 展示活動を
続けているんですけれども
2020年に 初めて
長崎の波佐見焼で作った陶磁器の
祈りの花瓶というものを発表しました
2021年は
東京で展示を開催しました
東京のオリンピックが開催されている
国立競技場の近くのアートギャラリーで
展示を開催したりしています
［展示ではどのような
反響がありましたか？］
2017年の展示では
コロナ前ということもあり
バックパッカーのお客さんが
展示に訪れてくださいました
その際に やはり
綺麗な瓶が並んでいる展示だと思って
ふらっと立ち寄って下さったんですけれども
作品の持つ背景や意味というものを知って
かなり驚かれる方が多かったです
ただ 作品を最後まで
きっちり見ていただいて
その後に 私に握手を求めて
来られる方だったり
あとは 涙を流して「ありがとう」というふうに
おっしゃってくださる方もいました
また 日本だけではなくて
海外でも展示を開催したらどうか
というふうに言ってくださる方も
いらっしゃいました
今年 2022年は 長崎の美術館で
祈りの花瓶展を開催しているんですけれども
地元の若いお客さんが
たくさん写真を撮って
日ごろ自分が思っている
平和への思いとか 平和への考えを
写真と共に SNSにアップしたり
そのような動きを
よく目にするようになりました
［ガラス瓶の3Dスキャンは
どのようにしたのですか？］
まずは 長崎の原爆資料館に
作品の企画書を送りまして
被爆瓶の貸し出し許可を
頂くとこからスタートしました
その後 透明な瓶というものは
普通の3Dスキャナーだと
形を採取できないというところで
いろいろ調べた結果
Ｘ線のCTスキャン装置なら
透明な物の3Dデータが取れる
というところにたどり着きました
そこで
長崎県の原爆資料館から
一番近いX線CTスキャン装置がある
場所というものが
福岡県の工業技術センターだったため
そこまで 被爆資料専門の運送業者さんに
被爆瓶３つを運んでいただきました
その後 ３つの被爆瓶を 半日ほどかけて
3Dデータを採取しました
［ガラス瓶の3Dモデルは
どのように作ったのですか？］
被爆したガラス瓶には
もともとの色もついていますし
被爆した時についた土の汚れだったり
あとは 熱で溶けたガラスの
つややかなシルエットというものがあります
これを忠実に再現するために
たどり着いたものが
UV硬化インクジェット方式という
3Dプリンターになります
その3Dプリンターは
着色もできるんですけれども
色の位置を指定することが
できないということで
元のガラス瓶の写真を見ながら
汚れだったり 色の濃度を
私がカラーデータを作りました
そのカラーデータを帯状にして
そのデータをもとに出力する際に
このように着彩していただきました
また この素材が
アクリル系の樹脂になっているので
3Dプリンターから出てきた後の蓄積痕を
きれいに磨き上げることで
このように被爆した瓶と同じような
瓶が溶けたツヤというものを再現できています
［なぜ写真や映像ではなく
実物体にする必要があったのですか？］
被爆地長崎には 被爆した資料というものが
たくさん残っているんですけれども
やはり そういうものが身近にない環境の方が
たくさんいらっしゃるということで
どうにかして
被爆した過去のことだったり
平和の大切さを継承したい
というふうに考えていました
ただ その被爆地長崎だったり
広島に足を運んで訪れるっていうことは
とてもハードルが高いことだと
考えているので
ただ 被爆した資料には
過去の悲惨さを伝えたり
平和の大切さを伝える
そういう貴重な資料としての力が
あると思っています
それをどうにかして
いろんな方に
気軽に触っていただけるようにできないか
というふうに考えました
そして それを作品に落とし込むことで
身近な生活に置いていただけたり
その瓶があることで
日常的にも 平和の大切さだったり
原爆の過去というものを
ふとした瞬間に思い出す
そういうことにつながるんじゃないかな
というふうに考えて
実物を作るようになりました
［なぜ陶磁器にしたのですか？］
作品を作る当初から
「陶磁器にしよう」というふうに
考えていたわけではないんですけれども
一番最初に作った作品が
ナイロン粉末の作品でした
ナイロン粉末だと
水を入れると漏れてしまったり
あとは 持つと
とても軽い素材になっています
そうすると 被爆瓶自体が持つ
「物」としての重さ
あとは その被爆瓶が持つ
「背景」としての重さというものを
作品で表現しづらいな
というふうに考えました
そこで 3Dデータをもとに
忠実に再現できながらも
重さ あとは 日常的に使える使いやすさ
というところから
長崎の波佐見焼というところに
たどり着きました
長崎の波佐見焼は
長崎で住む人たちにとっては
とても日常的に使われる
なじみの深い陶磁器になっています
そして 長崎はやはり 被爆者の方も
たくさんいらっしゃいますし
被爆遺構もたくさんある
日常的に
原爆のことだったり
平和について考えるきっかけが多い
というところで
日常的に使われている波佐見焼というものを
作品で使うことにしました
［将来どのような展示をしたいですか？］
将来は この展示活動を
海外で行いたいというふうに思っています
といいますのも
やはり 2017年当初の展示には
たくさん海外から
お客さんがいらっしゃいました
その方たちに
この作品を通してであれば
原爆の被害にあった方々の
平和への思いだったり
あとは 1945年8月9日
過去に起きたことというものを
アートを通じて伝えることが
できるんじゃないかな
というふうに考えています
［「祈りの花瓶」に込めた
メッセージを教えてください］
1945年の8月9日に
長崎に投下された原爆について
多くの人に知ってもらいたい
という思いと
あとは 被爆者の方々が訴えてきた
平和への思い
平和への祈りというものを
作品に込めました
そして 作品を通じて
アートの側面からだったり
被爆資料として さらには
身近に置いて平和を祈る花瓶として
本当に色んな方向から 平和の大切さを
伝えていける作品だと思っています
私自身 被爆３世で
平和の大切さというものを
分かっているつもりではあるんですけれども
やはり まだまだ
世界では戦争が起きていたり
争いごとが絶えないというところで
海外の人たちとともに
展示を通して
どういうふうなことをしたら
もっと争いがない世界になるか
また 平和の大切さというものを
みんなで再認識して
今後の平和な世界を どうやったら
作っていけるかっていうことを
作品を通して一緒に考えていきたい
そういうふうに思っています
今までの原爆をテーマにした作品というものは
いろいろ存在するんですけれども
やはり 目を背けてしまいたくなるような
表現が多かったりするんですが
やはり 今 若い世代の平和意識が
低下しているとか
継承を危ぶまれる中で
どうやったら興味がない人たちに
訴えれるかということを 常に考えてきました
そうですね
この作品を通してであれば
やはり いろんな若い世代だったり
あとは海外の人たちにも
平和への思いを
受け取ってもらえるんじゃないかな
というふうに考えています